اذا 37 يوما تفصل روسيا واوكرانيا عن
الذكرى الاولى لانطلاق حرب دروس بينهما في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي ذكرى لا
يتمنى اي طرف منهما الا ان يحتفل بها
منتصرا ولكن من سيبلغ نصاب الفوز ليس
واضحا لان كليهما يبذلان ما بوسعهما لنيل
هذا النصر روسيا كانت شنت الهجوم بدعوه
الحاجه الى نزع السلاح واجتثاث النازيه من
اوكرانيا اضافه الى منعها من الانضمام
للنيته وحمايه الروس الذين يقتلونه هناك
ومنذ اول انفجار شنته على مباني في كيافه
ظل تصف ما تقوم به بالعمليه الخاصه قصف
ودمار
وقتلى واسلحه كل ذلك يدرس لدى موسكو
بالعمليه الخاصه حتى دموع هذا الصبي لا
تزال تمطر حزنا على فراق وطنه وابيه الذي
ابا الا ان تمزح عائلته ويدافعه عن ارضها
لكن وبعد مرور نحو احد عشر شهرا وجدت
روسيا نفسها بعيده عن تحقيق الهدف لانها
وجدت سدا منيعا من الاوكرانيين لم تكن
تتوقعه الدليل ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ولاول مره منذ بدا النزاع قال اننا
نواجه حربا وحربا طويله الامد زاد عليها
في تصريحات اليوم ان غرور القاده
الاوكرانيين لم يمكن من انهاء الحرب سلميه
لا اعلم ولكن اتمنى ان تنتهي قريبا
لكن لا اظن انها ستنتهي هذا العام
ليس لدي اجابه
انا اؤمن
القوه
نحن سننتصر
عندما يحدث لكم اننا في كل الاحوال لا
يمكن هزيمه الاوكرانيين
لا استطيع ان نخمن لكن سيحدث ذلك عاجلا ام
اجلا
لا احد يملك توقيتا بطبيعه الحال البعض
يملك امال فقط تقول صحيفه نيوز ويك
الامريكيه ان روسيا باتت تتجه الان لتغيير
موقفها وتتعامل مع الواقع على ان ما يجري
في اوكرانيا حرب تقليديه كبرى ووافقه معهد
دراسه الحرب فان المعركه قد تصبح حربا
شامله يسخر فيها احد طرفين نزاع او كلاهما
معظم الثروات الماديه والبشريه المتوفره
للمجهود الحربي ومع اقتراب اليوم الذي حول
سماء اوكرانيا الى اجواء مدجزه بالطائرات
والمسيرات الحربيه تكثف كاف الدعوات الى
زياده امدادها بالاسلحه من الدول الغربيه
حيث
قالوف سكرتير مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكراني قال ان كيف تتوقع ان تحاول
القوات الروسيه القيام بما يسمى بالدفعه
الاخيره في ذكرى العمليه العسكريه في
الرابع والعشرين من براير المقبل ووفقا
نيوز ويك فان الكرام لاند كان قد اتخذ
تدابيره لتدارك اخطاء الحمله العسكريه
الروسيه بما في ذلك تعبئه نحو الثلاثمائه
الف جندي واجراءات صناعيه واقتصاديه لخدمه
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا حتى الان بل
ويدور حديث عن ان بوتن وضع تكليفات محدده
امام القائد الجديد للعمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا كاتيا
مع اختنا بالعمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا من عامها الاول تزداد تقارير
الخبراء العسكريين والسياسيين التي تتحدث
عن التوقيت المحتمل في انتهاء الصراع
ويعرضون خيراتهم حول كيفيه التوصل الى
هدنه محتمله وحول ما اذا كانت ستنتهي قبل
الرابعه و20 من فبراير او في مارس كما
تحدث تقارير اوكرانيه عن ان الرئيس الروسي
اصدرت تعليمات لقائد العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا للسيطره على دوم بس بحلول شهر
مارس 2023
والتي رفض الكرام التعليق عليها وبعد ذلك
يتوقع خبراء وروس ان تقوم موسكو مع حلول
الصقيع بزياده العمليات الهجوميه هناك
والتي تعكس رغبه الرئيس الروسي القديمه
في اقرب وقت ممكن كما تحدث مسبقا
اذا بدا بوتن كمن لدغ من جحر مره او مرتين
او ثلاثا لا فرق المهم والاكيد ان التغيير
يبدو مطلوبا الان وربما لهذا صيغه خطه
تبدو في طريقها للتنفيذ في طريق في طريقها
للتنفيذ اذن وعنوانها سيكون تعزيز الجيش
بما اوتيت موسكو من قوه استعدادا لحسم
المعركه فبعد سلسله من الانتكاسات قدم
وزير الدفاع سيرجيو جدولا زمنيا لزياده
القوات ضمن اجراءات واسعه النطاق في
الفتره الممتده من العام الجاري وحتى عام
2026 من الواضح ان الحرب ستكون طويله اذا
قال ان تعداد القوات المسلحه الروسيه سوف
يرتفع الى مليون ونصف مقارنه بمليون
و150,000 في العام الماضي اضافه الى
انشائي مناطق عسكريه جديده المناطق
المحيطه بالعاصمه موسكو وسان بيتروس بارك
على الحدود الانديه واكد المتحدث بس من
الرئاسه الروسيه
ان سبب زياده تعداد عسكريين يكمن في
تصرفات الغرب وضروره الضمان ان البلاد دون
قيد او شرط فيما اسماه حربا بالوكاله وعلى
حد تعبيره فكل الطواقي العسكريه تعمل على
قدم وساق على مدار الساعه لزياده قدراتها
العسكريه خاصه من اولئك المسؤولين عن
توريد الاسلحه وصناعتها وبعد تعيين
الجنرال فاليري جراسيموف قائد الاعلى
للحرب في اوكرانيا ستبدو امامه المهم اصعب
لانه قطع وعدا امام بوتن بان بان يستخدم
تكتيكات اكثر عدوانيه لكسر الجمودي على
الارض